an atheist edward i'm at my
croissan'wich and the NFL he is a
Central European University with an
internet microsoft this summer okay and
so what we are what we're interested in
is basically going to understand social
news consumption so we mean with that
news news that's consumed through
Facebook for example or Twitter where
you know there's a link and you click on
it and it takes you to a newspaper
article say okay and you know if if you
think this is not sort of a important
phenomena is actually immaculate
unsurprisingly most people these days
have some social media profile and
social media and increasingly important
source of news so the pew pew did
various service about this in 2011
twenty-seven percent of adults regularly
yet reported that they regularly get
news from their social networks and
between the 2012 primaries twenty
percent regularly got updates from
Facebook five percent from Twitter and
you know unsurprisingly it's more
concentrated for the younger people 18
to 29 year olds 52-percent get news from
facebook okay and this was an LA Times
poll and you know if you asked websites
then in 2011 they reported that about
nine percent of their traffic comes from
from social media Facebook and Twitter
again is the main drivers here just to
compare that like you know for example
for the New York Times in 2011 the
numbers about six percent what six
percent comes from facebook and twitter
this was before the paywall forty
percent also comes from aggregators from
google news yahoo news and so on and you
know the rest is direct navigation and
that's in a big increase in that ok so
it's just sort of setting this this
stage that that social media consumption
consuming news that is sort of filtered
through your social network has become
more important ok and and so what we are
interested in is what effect does this
have on overall news consumption so you
know for example you you previously
spend to our you know this is pretty
much you spend like
number of hours they say you spend an
hour a day on on use your new sound and
you just go to your favorite websites
you consume news this way and now say
half of your news is still directly
navigated and the other half comes from
reading articles that your friends post
on social networks okay now question
there is you know will for example the
distribution of topics change it's
possible that for example maybe people
will consume more sports or less sports
or more celebrity news okay will they
may be like report you know maybe they
consume more trendy topics maybe what's
filter through social networks is is
more trendy and less sort of like
long-term topics or maybe it's the other
way around maybe actually what people do
in social networks is they they signal
to their friends that they are sort of
thinkers and you know they like to post
articles about global warming because
that sort of shows them that do you know
that you are so a deep thinker and
you're not just caught into the topic of
the day okay it could go and buyers
direction so we are interested in like
and what actually does the data tell us
particular issue he is bias you know
there's some of these all these stories
about you know Sunstein's is this the
echo chamber in fact that if you are if
you're communicating within your social
network you know maybe you because of
whom awfully you are you're talking to
people of your own types of your
conservative you talk to fellow
conservatives they tend to filter news
which is conservative and consequently
you read more conservative news or more
liberal news of your liberal okay and
you know recently there was a paper by
you know mechanical and jesse shapiro
who'd like argue actually that's not
necessarily true you know they argued
that if you just compare offline use to
online news they didn't look at social
media news but if you look at online
news and offline use online use is not
obviously more biased than offline use
okay but we don't know what the thing is
these social media news and they also
argue that might be actually some some
measure measurement issue because they
they measure bias on the on the
publisher level we measure bias on the
article level but i'll show that you in
a second okay and other issues which we
are looking at but we are
not you know I can't show you any
results about that yet is is there's a
supply demand story so let's say that
you know social media news consumption
is significantly different from direct
news consumption is this driven by
supply is this driven by what your
friends post or is it driven by demand
what you click on depending on like you
know you know condition on going to
Facebook or Twitter are you clicking on
certain types of articles more
frequently so that would be a demand
affect the supply effect would be you
know what actually do your friends post
ok and Twitter is actually kind of nice
we can do this on Twitter very nicely
because twitter has this feature that
whatever is being posted is
chronologically listed on facebook
that's much harder to do because
facebook has EdgeRank and so partially
supply is influenced I mean greatly
influenced presumably by EdgeRank and so
it's not just influenced by what your
friends post it's also influenced by
what facebook decides to show okay so
this is something which we virtually
focusing on on Twitter okay so let me
tell you what what data we are using him
so we using Microsoft has toolbar you
know google has has its own toolbar many
of these are these firms use toolbars to
like collect research data about
Internet users so in this case we have
several million anonymous users in the
US we know which URL say visit and we
have an anonymous ID which tells us so
it allows us to like say this user went
on these websites of different days okay
and we also know for each website they
have a referrer so we know exactly where
they come from so if you go for example
to an article in New York Times we know
if you come from google news or yahoo
news or if you come from Facebook or
Twitter or if you come from an internal
page in you in the New York Times ok so
the latter we would we would classify
his direct navigation if it comes from
facebook or twitter that would be social
navigation if it comes from from google
news it would be aggregator traffic
right now and there you also have to
distinguish a little bit because for
example sometimes you'll go to new store
google com and then they read
news.google.com like
regional newspaper and they click on it
sometimes what they do is a search on
Google and they see some articles and
they click on the articles okay one the
first one is pretty much passive
browsing the second one is you actively
search for something okay so the first
part is more similar to drag navigation
even though the news is created by
google where's the I second one is
fundamentally different where you
actually search for something but I
won't get into those details okay um so
we get so we get the the for different
users we get the URL so we know what
they browse and we know what comes from
direct navigation bookmarks or like you
know New York Times going to another new
york times article and what comes from
social media and the next thing we do is
we capture the text of these URLs so we
go and we capture the text and Microsoft
is nicely they have the bing indexed for
the bing search engine and so that gives
us actually for most articles say the
text so we don't have to scrape it
because he's a millions of article you
just get that from from this from the
index okay so this is this is so this
gives us the actual article text and
then we can classified in various ways
and some of it we classify using
automated methods and some of it we use
the crowd sourcing for that okay and an
ongoing work you know we use the Twitter
fire hose Microsoft has access to a
Twitter fire hose which people's us
access to all the tweets being posted
and that can like you know shed light on
this supply demand question I mentioned
before okay all right so what I'm
talking about today is is is a sample
this is a pilot we ran the summer which
is you know we only focus 117 use sides
we are we doing it right now for like
six thousand news sites which we think
is pretty much the universe of new sites
in the US but the hundred seventeen top
new sites were taken from danskin
Shapiro okay and so we this is the
sample you're taking and you know
there's some technical issues about how
to get referral information where they
come from let me not not get into that
now the question of what is the news
outlet is actually
a very good one because news outlet
change all the time you know new
websites are renamed etc and you know
this this website you know these hundred
seventeen sides we used were you know
they were chosen by by against concha
pure like four years ago but the site is
actually this list is kind of out of
date if you look at it you see that it's
you know that many of the rankings they
assume have changed in the meantime okay
so we're now building a more accurate
list which is essentially doing the
following method we just look at all the
referrals that come from google news and
yahoo news and we built a published a
list out of that because we assume
anything referred from those big
machines is basically a new site okay
now that works most of the time it gives
us all the big newspapers etc it also
sometimes gives us things like you know
walmart has a press announcement okay
and that's a problem because I via
walmart.com in there and Bowl marcom
actually has a lot of traffic much most
of its like people shopping online and
and so that's a problem so they actually
have to create that list and we do that
again through crowdsourcing in order to
like cut down on the actual domains we
want okay and you know this is how the
crowd source you near and we started off
with about 10,000 slightly less than
10,000 10,000 domains that are referred
from google or yahoo news and then what
we do is we crowdsource those we show
people screenshots we get screenshots
for each of the sites we show crowd
workers and amazon screenshots and then
they tell us if it's an english side or
not if it's a new site or not if it's a
magazine or newspaper etc okay or a blog
and and that cuts it down so what we
getting in the end is a list of about
six thousand sites okay we think that's
a pretty you know that's a pretty
complete set of new sites and if you
know if you're interested in like
getting access to that you know just
ends I me an email and I can show you
that and share that with you okay now so
we have so we have the URLs the other
news now how do we we get we get them
once we have the URL we get to get all
the older we get bigger the text now the
next thing is we have to somehow
classify that
and what we discovered is what's really
important is you have to actually first
of all understand the topics that are in
these newspapers okay if you don't have
the topics things are very hard to do
for example crowdsourcing for political
bias is very difficult if you show
people completely random newspaper
articles if you show them like a sports
and then you show them something about
Benghazi and then chosen something about
Obamacare and then about IRS scandal or
whatever you know the sort of you know
you get very very noisy thing it's much
better if you show people about a
particular topic lots of articles for
example if you show them about you know
IRS this was a big news topic and like
you know the summer if you show them
about this this this IRS scandal or
whatever your position is if you show
them this you show them like you know
articles from Fox News where New York
Times on all these other publications
they are much better and sort of unless
you know telling you what the bias its
relative bias of these of these articles
okay because you don't be only show them
the article text you don't show them
it's New York Times and so but you know
what we discovered is we first did it
without topics and let me discover that
we really have to like actually good you
know look at topics otherwise this crowd
sourcing is very very noisy so we do is
we we take all these articles and we map
one third of them we discovers about 130
I should be very nicely map directly
until I give pedia news articles so
wikipedia has like lots of news articles
about specific events and you know we
can just use text mining to basically
yep topics which come directly from
headings and so on the others do you try
using topic modeling with humans then
trying to put it now you need it because
we didn't use yeah we didn't use human
see what we did is Bobby this is for
example I can we use Wikipedia snapshot
so this is data from April and May of
this year abusive Wikipedia snapshot
from like June okay so that Wikipedia
snapshot actually already has like you
know particular articles about most of
the big news events okay and if you look
for keywords and by grams and then in
the in the in the various newspaper
articles and you basically can map most
of them already very nicely to these
Vicky PD articles okay and that works
for about one-third very very
okay and for the other third we do
something like topic modeling so we
actually use sort of an algorithm which
is used by by big news okay and what
that does is it creates show you that
how much time do I have until four okay
fine good good yeah so so forth let me
just ask Arden the Wikipedia thing I
mean it's you know it's probably like
you know you know very very obvious for
most of you how we did this so we you
just took the Wikipedia snapshot the
extract the keywords and by grams and we
attach a tf-idf score which is sort of a
score you know standard you know
information retrieval technique of an
you know of basically like how
indicative that's you know how
distinctive that word is okay so example
the word an your and well annville PA
stuff but like you know certain words
like give also would have very low score
and other things like Obama or McCain or
so they would have high scores because
they are distinctive and you generally
have high scores if you if this word
appears in a few articles okay like for
example McCain only appears usually in
articles which are about politics or
Obama the same and so the relatively
distinctive word okay so you have these
scores and then what we do is we have
these keywords and key by grams then we
take a newspaper article and then we
extract the keywords and by grams we
rank them and then be compared with all
the Wikipedia articles they are and we
look for the same keywords and by grams
there and we look for the sort of the
best matching ones okay we use up to
three good matches so that gives us for
each newspaper article up to like three
matches this way and then we look at the
distribution of all the articles we
selected this way and we take you know
the 50 top ones and this is sort of what
we take as the is basically the target
for this Wikipedia ranking and you know
it sort of select basically what you
would expect it selects you know the top
news articles selects like enough for
may and april it selects lots of
articles on it selects the
on the Boston bombing on Benghazi on IRS
exactly these kinds of articles okay and
then be associated newspaper articles to
those clusters and that works for about
a third of them okay now the other third
is we use the sort of clustering method
which is used by these search engines
fly cluster news news topics and
essentially what it does is we take each
each newspaper article as a sort of node
and then we say the link the link
strength between two nodes is sort of
how similar they are in terms of the
words and by grams they use okay and
then we also look at semantic similarity
we map each of those two like in a
Wikipedia articles and we see how these
wikipedia articles overlap use both of
those we construct this network okay we
overlay this network actually then with
our Wikipedia networks so any any kind
of nodes which belong to a Wikipedia
cluster which I've identified in the
first stage we just make a complete sub
network and then add the sort of
auxiliary network I just constructed and
then we look for clusters we just use
community detection Weezer motorization
algorithm to actually then discover the
various clusters okay what that does is
it on one second it uncovers basically
the classes we started as a Wikipedia
clusters but it also gives us new ones
which is covered by these by these words
similarities yes we did we use the
weights yes so we experimented with it a
little bit so so what we did is we use a
fairly high weight like you know if in
this complete network defined by these
wikipedia articles we use a fairly high
weight because we wanted to uncover
those again and then the use sort of
slightly lower weights for the forward
similarity and for semantic similarity
okay that's that's what we did okay and
you know and then then we get sort of
that allows us to basically the world or
two-thirds of the articles we can sort
of assigned to clean clusters this way
okay so instead of one-third we double
it to about two-thirds that basically is
one-third is the old Wikipedia clusters
we had also now what we usually do
we actually add some articles which we
which slipped through our filter before
but we attached to the DPD are clusters
now because of bird similarity and we
identify some completely new ones okay
so for example there was I mean this was
a horrible story but there was some baby
in some country which was flushed down
the toilet there was no Vicki pedia
article about this i was a baby survived
fortunately but it was there was no
biggie pedia article about this but you
know the the I wouldn't picked it up
from the world similarity okay so this
was a class clear where we wouldn't have
picked it up as Wikipedia but we picked
it up because of this disgusting method
and then we still left with one-third of
articles which we cannot assign and
those basically we just samuel into
singleton topics which is take a sample
from then a weighted sample if you put
them to singleton topics because we
don't know what else to do with them
they tend to be some sort of unique
articles which we cannot really attached
anywhere I mean one-third is pretty big
but that's why we are left with okay so
this is for example 11 sample articles
the one sample cluster this is a this
headline is this is this is from a
Wikipedia article these are sort of the
various in newspaper articles which
belong to that cluster and you can see
that most of them were were picked up by
this Wikipedia method but some of them
were not picked up by this ever picked
up by this world similarity and later
attached to it okay now we have these
articles we have these topics and now
what we want to do is we want to we want
to classify them when to classify the
topics and we want to classify the
articles and so we had crowdsource you
know get crowdsource work on Amazon Turk
we built this crowdsourcing platform and
basically we showed them so this is for
a Wikipedia topic we showed them the
Wikipedia article so that they could
actually read up on it so they had a
clear idea about this topic is about
okay and then we showed them some sample
articles they could go here and these
sample articles but just a pure text so
we ran you know we just ran an algorithm
on these various newspaper articles to
just extract the article text to get rid
of all the images to get rid of the
newspaper itself okay to just take all
of this context that way just just the
itself and then we just ask them on the
on the topic level you know this is
about crime about government about
disasters is this politics business
science and so on is this a topic which
potentially could have political bias
some of them can't I mean like sometimes
or Red Sox winning something I mean we
don't you know most people say that's
come to have a political bias that's not
me and so we do this on the article
level and then in a second step for each
within each topic we do a second
classification crowdsourcing on the
article where each article is
individually analyzed took him and sort
of oops
yeah so topics classification I just
described in the article level each
article is is an opinion article but
research what kind of emotions does it
raise positive negative emotions whom is
it targeted at targeted men women
teenagers young people etc it's all
about the author's intention is it
critical is it positive ok so we try to
sort of get as many sort of features out
of this as possible alright and you know
we did this because our assumption was
that you know if you really want to get
political bias for example if you want
to get certain features it's difficult
to get them really with automated
methods so we try to run like you know
some automated methods and we discover
that especially in the article level
they don't work very well ok for example
i can again squish appear use something
on the on the publisher level most of
these methods for example which are
supposed to like analyze political bias
they're going to publish a level not in
the article level ok and effectively
what they do a little bit they look at
the topic distribution and they say for
example like you know get scrappy look
at during the iraq war and tend to to be
the case that you know more conservative
you know more conservative newspapers
tended to report about certain topics
more okay and so this is being picked up
but this method actually works pretty
badly if you do in an article level but
for example if you look at Wall Street
Journal most of the articles and Wall
Street Journal have no political bias
whatsoever the opinion page has a very
strong political bias but actually the
news page doesn't have it so much if you
go to Fox News you know lots of them
about sports which also don't have much
political bias okay but of course if you
go to the commentators you know they
have they're pretty strong political
violence so we tried very hard to do
everything on the article level okay so
let me show you some of the if you
compare direct navigation with social
browsing let me show some some of the
patterns you see here so green here is
always dark navigation and red is
browsing and no it looks like here you
know people people who use social media
to consume news it looks like you know
they consume more celebrities and more
crime much less sports
more disasters there's not really a big
difference in business of science but
you know these are very low levels to
start with okay so so so they are
certain so this is this is just on the
super topics okay the main topics what
are the what are sort of the the
patterns there and you can see some
differences yet it seems like in a
certain certain emotional I mean certain
things like celebrities crime here are
you know a slightly I mean especially
celebrity nooz a stronger sports is much
much less these are all the page views
so i'll do a composition by user a show
that it is actually very very good
question but this is just page views
okay all the social page views you know
what but are sort of the features of
this and all the direct pageviews okay
if you look at polarization so we look
at so he is actually this this we do by
users we distinguish users by those who
are in that diagonal vacation more or
less conservative okay we just divide
them up in the middle okay and then when
you do that you see that the liberal
users you know unsurprisingly they have
more diary I mean this is by
construction they direct you know they
go more to liberal sites in the diagonal
vacation by actually a social navigation
is even stronger okay and the same is
true for conservatives just the other
way around okay so this is actually a
kind of an echo chamber effect here okay
that you know these these tendencies
which exists in direct browsing are sort
of amplified when you go to social
browsing okay when you go to article
content you know they're relatively
actually small difference if you look at
things like in-depth article is a
controversial topic opinion articles
there's some some small differences but
it's not huge if you look at emotions
they're bigger differences here overall
social browsing tends to sort of be
arise stronger emotions okay and you
know question might be maybe that's
driven by topics because I also show
these mobile disasters mobile
celebrities and so on so i'll show you
pre composition a second about that and
then targeting oh you know there is no
obvious targeting by education but it
seems to be that gender targeting so
most of our crowd worker source said
that the social media articles at target
mode women okay and then you know you
aren't wonder like maybe this is sort of
driven by the fact that men women chair
differently okay so and all that's
intention it seems to be that that all
you know people the the articles that
are being shared are the ones that are
the less neutral ones you know the more
either positive or negative or critical
okay which goes together the sort of
this idea body motion now here we do a
user decomposition so what we do is the
following we just say our worry is that
maybe people browser different
intensities okay so maybe like for
example old people and young people they
go to social media for their consumption
at very different weights okay and
that's really what sort of behind those
differences okay so what we do is we do
the following we look at direct browsing
we look at the users who have direct and
soldier browsing and then we assume that
all of them we just rebate their social
browsing assuming that all of them
browse at the same intensity as a browse
directly okay yep so it's mad for
example Matt and I we have the same diet
browsing but I browse I mean I have
double as many social page views as Matt
in this exercise we just equalize that
okay we just rebate mine by a factor of
a half in order to like make it equal
okay yep alright so if you do that it's
kind of interesting actually for example
the sports thing here goes I mean
many on the super topics the difference
is almost completely away okay so sports
you know if you thought maybe maybe the
story is that that you know people don't
share sports news no it's not that it's
just that the people who read sports
they don't share as much okay the people
who don't read as much sports you know
they tend to share more and that sort of
drives these differences okay so it's
very important that you control actually
for the user recomposition good news for
us is is that polarization is actually
not really explained by that so if you
control for the user recomposition you
don't explain that so it's not the case
for example that the more extreme users
are the ones who use social media more
which could otherwise drive this
polarization thing so that doesn't seem
to be it okay ah and if you look at the
other dimensions you know sort of it's a
mixed story like you know basically some
of it you know on average about sort of
half of the half of the variation BC
before is explained by user
decomposition okay all right now let me
show you the last couple of slides as we
just do this by by topics so what we do
is we relayed by topics so what I argue
is that it's very it's very important to
control for user composition when you
control the user composition a lot of
the differences go away now we also
control for topic ok so we control for
the fact that you know we look at like
you know how much residual difference is
remaining after you control for the fact
that you know social browsing more about
celebrity then about save science okay
and so if you do that you know basically
what you see is that you know it's again
that's about half of half of you know
the topics are important but not not as
important as the users so what half of
it half of the remaining stuff is
explained with with the topic
decomposition and then the residual the
residual differences that are remain is
is sort of neither explained by user
know by top ET composition okay so the
so what are we doing here while we
described like you know how news is
consumed
threes various channels social media and
and diagonal gation and what we trying
to do is basically the time to argue
this is very important that you you
understand what individual users do
because you don't do that you know what
you might just be picking up as a
substitution effect okay you might just
be picking up that people sort of browse
social media at different rates and if
they drop you know if they do it at
different rates may be their social news
consumption exactly the same as a
diagnosed consumption okay just happens
to be the case that you know young
people substitute like half of their
diet browsing for social browsing and
old people substitute nothing okay now
that would be effect then we there
wouldn't really be any policy
implications from the shift because it
wouldn't really affect on an individual
loser level it wouldn't really affect
what these people do okay and you know
this is part of the story so it seems to
explain like you know most of the
differences in terms of what we see
about celebrity is about crime but it
doesn't explain is a sort of this
residual like a residual differences for
example and polarization ok so what but
be trying to do is basically
differentiate differentiate the effects
that I explained by by by differences in
user intensity and then see what's
remaining okay and then see what policy
implications can we get from that ok and
so so far it looks like you know we have
residual polarization remaining even
after you control for users